il compte de la mode et visionnaire
thierry mugler a créé certaines des plus
belles silhouettes des années 80 90
c'est vrai que j'ai tendance à aimer les
livres les vrais de vrais à les
fabriquer marketing donc les vrais
talents des vraies bêtes de saint-louis
femmes moto femme robot femme insecte ou
femme au chapeau
thierry mugler et le grand couturier de
la métamorphose lui-même à sculpter son
corps à un tel point que les müller des
années 80 ne ressemble plus aux
milliards d'aujourd'hui
lille et celle équilibre dans la beauté
du corps humain c'est aussi la symétrie
c'est ce qu'on cherche en musculation
c'est la symétrie
c'est très difficile le musée des
beaux-arts de montréal frappe un grand
coup en produisant cette exposition de
150 tenues créées par mugler
le couturier avait toujours refusé
auparavant qu'on l'exposent dans un
musée à vrai dire le contact s'est fait
les yeux dans les yeux
au delà des mots ça a été une chose
d'instinctif je suis vraiment crif et le
pré vernissage a fait courir les foules
la vedette kim kardashian était de la
fête et après montréal
cette exposition fera le tour du monde
ce sera le plus long défilé de monsieur
mugler puisque l'exposition va commencer
son parcours aux pays-bas en allemagne
probablement suite en france aux états
unis et cetera et cetera
pour les designers d'ici cette
exposition est un véritable happening
complètement dans les années 80 j'étais
fan de trémie de la même chose avec jean
paul gaultier
il faisait des défilés c'était
spectaculaire c'était le glamour à son
paroxysme c'est pourquoi du vêtement
mais on va au delà de ça c'est un
univers qui est assez lourd qu'un
univers assez bande dessinée aussi
au sommet de sa gloire thierry mugler a
cessé de faire de la conception de
costumes il ya plus de 15 ans et il ne
songe pas y revenir
j'ai des très gros projet de mise en
scène donc non je pars à l'ordre du jour
mais encore aujourd'hui le style mugler
inspire de nombreux créateurs ici louis
fait depuis mai radio canada montréal